mesdames et messieurs bonsoir il s'est
produit hier soir dans la vie politique
internationale
un fait sans précédent un très haut
diplomate parlant devant la plus haute
instance de l'onu s'est mis à critiquer
avec violence la politique de son propre
pays cela s'est passé au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu l'ambassadeur andrew
yang chef de la représentation
américaine mais limogés
vous le savez il ya quelques jours
présidait pour la dernière fois la
séance du conseil de sécurité
elle était consacrée aux droits des
palestiniens monsieur yang a d'abord
prononcé un discours officiel pour
exposer la position officielle du
gouvernement de washington puis
considérant les débats comme clos il a
attaqué l'instant d'après avec véhémence
et dans la même enceinte
la politique étrangère de monsieur
kerpert le refus du gouvernement
américain de parler avec l'ol paie est
ridicule
tout comme le refus de certains pays
arabes de dialoguer avec israël
insistant sur le fait qu'il ne parlait
qu'en son propre nom monsieur yang a
lancé un appel solennel à tous les pays
du proche orient pour qu'ils renoncent à
la violence
depuis 30 ans at il dit la violence n'a
rien fait gagner ni à israël ni aux
paysages niant qu'il y est eu un
désaccord personnel entre le président
carter et lui-même y en ait insisté sur
le fait qu'il était depuis longtemps
opposé à la politique américaine de
refus du dialogue avec les palestiniens
en acceptant de rencontrer le
représentant de l'ol paie a dit mme
jiang
je n'ai fait que respecter mes
responsabilités envers mon pays envers
les idéaux et les principes rue qu'elle
je crois c'est le refus de dialoguer
avec la chine populaire a poursuivi yang
qui a causé la guerre de corée qui a
entré chez les américains de mettre fin
rapidement à la guerre du vietnam enfin
monsieur gagne a exprimé l'espoir que
son geste pourrait changer la politique
américaine vis-à-vis des palestiniens
je ne pouvais y perdre que mon poste
d'ambassadeur à l'onu at il dit et
aujourd'hui je ne regrette rien
nous reviendrons aux questions de
l'international tout à l'heure en france
reprises des incendies de forêts dans le
midi dans l'arrière-pays niçois le feu
est arrivé près de la station émettrice
de tdf télédiffusion de france et à un
autre endroit
ils menacent l'autoroute a8 situation à
nouveau critique ce soir à roquebrune
cap martin dans les alpes-maritimes la
progression du feu qui semble est paix
en fin de matinée a repris avec plus
d'intensité attisés par des vents
violents de plus de 60 kilomètres heure
progressant dans deux directions à la
fois vers les hauteurs et la mer le feu
a surpris les sapeurs pompiers quatre
canadair se relaient depuis le début de
l'après midi une centaine de pompiers et
des dizaines de véhicules s'efforce de
protéger la base militaire du mont agel
et les villes abordant la grande
corniche entre nice et monaco à 20
heures le feu menaçait toujours la
station émettrice radio monte carlo dans
le var les six foyers qui va être éclaté
hier après midi au dessus du lavandou
sont tous circonscrit ce soir mais c'est
plus de 350 hectares de chênes et de
garrigue qui ont été détruits
autour de vacances les automobilistes
n'ont guère eu lieu la nuit dernière la
conduite est un difficile à cause de la
pluie et celle ci d'ailleurs va
continuer au nord de la loire la
circulation à ce bras était fluide à peu
près partout sauf entre bayonne et
poitiers demain devrait être normal mais
attention à l'approché des grandes
villes
les retours de week-end seront dit on
très dense en rentrant il faudra
reprendre le collier et retrouver les
problèmes de la vie quotidienne
notamment celui les prix des fruits et
légumes
l'institut national de consommation
donne quelques conseils
abstenez-vous d'acheter des haricots
verts et les mangetout ils sont chers
les tomates au contraire baisse ou devez
en trouver de belles entre de francs est
de 50
le raisin chasselas ne doit pas être
payée au dessus de 5 50 le kilo et pour
les poires bio ne m'étais pas plus de
260 mais en général le public s'étonne à
juste titre de la disparité entre les
prix à la production et les prix de
vente au détail nous avons voulu suivre
la filière d'une laitue et bien ça n'a
pas été facile pour expliquer ce qui se
passe entre le producteur et le
consommateur
les volontaires ne se bousculent pas au
micro certains ont refusé de répondre à
nos questions notamment ceux qu'on
appelle les deuxième grossiste et
certains détaillants soit indépendant
soit deux magasins à succursales et
l'équipe de gérard dalmaz a dû se
contenter de suivre ce que l'on appelle
le circuit court production coopérative
de gros plus de détails en bref ceux qui
ont bien voulu recevoir notre huitième
ceinture maraîchère de paris à l'aube et
à la demande de la coopérative de gros
le producteur coupe un certain nombre de
belles laitue épargné par les pucerons
en juin juillet cette qualité était
acheté 35 à 50 centimes un prix de
misère disaient les professionnels
on nous paye en vue en la pièce de
saladin francs 33
on a à peu près 23 centimes de frais
d'emballage
ce qui fait que la pièce de laitue et
enfin il nous reste pour la pièce de
lecture francs 10 d'ici le 15 septembre
les lectures reprendre peut-être dupuis
puisqu'elles seront relativement rares
décidément il manque 10 mille hectares
de serres enfance en tout cas un
répondent certains consommateurs comment
joue pas de la laitue les prix montent
quand même toutefois la marge de cette
coopérative reste corinthe commence à se
faire comment vous n'auriez pas faire
pouffer de la belle balade part il ya le
temps qu'ils jouent
et puis
bon je vais te mettre dans deuxième
catégorie un taux net
voyage pourquoi tu la mettes en extra
monsieur français dans la catégorie où
il était classé nous lui avons payé en
france 33 1.33 la pièce ces marchandises
ne les avons vendu suivant l'endroit que
nous avons livré entre 1,50 et 1,60 la
pièce c'est dramatique côté consommateur
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'a toujours
une explication où c'est le mauvais
temps ou non c'est à dire il serait sous
ce sont les importations l'impression
que personne n'est fautif qu'un socle
les événements majeurs extérieur wii
nommé le consommateur je pense qu'il ya
une chose qui se rappellent pas c'est
que maintenant le consommateur du 1er
janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre
il veut de tout dans son assiette et ça
il faut qu'il pense une chose qui a les
intempéries et on a font dépend du temps
tout le temps c'est le temps qui nous
commande alors qu elle n'y a pas de
l'étude il faut qu'ils mangent autre
chose tva sur toutes les opérations
fruits légumes et réforme de la
distribution
le monstre du loch ness réapparaît à
chaque marée des prix pourtant avec le
système actuel et les services offerts
le pouls du circuit traditionnel est
incompressible sur certains points
transports ou encore présence du détail
auprès de l'acheteur
à combien achetez-vous par la pièce bien
sûr chaque l'étude nous avons payé ce
matin france 50 caisses de l'état hors
taxes et vous la revendre à combien leur
vendons de francs 20 valley utah projet
comme toutes les salades c'est un
produit taxé à coefficient de 1 50
comme nous sommes durs et à domicile
nous déduisons 0,05 tr 5 centimes par
feuille de laitue à ceux qui face à caen
par à 50 rires 225 500 pink de francs 20
apparemment une affaire pas simple mais
rentable à côté du gâchis vingt tonnes à
l'hectare que subissent certains
producteurs de pommes cardinal de
provence on nous paye les pommes à
environ 45 kg kg on les retrouve à
combien on n'aurait pas marché on
retrouve dans de 4 à 5 la gpe remâché
4,5 france ne t'appartiennent prix super
machine on retrouve sommes à 45 10 mois
n'en paient pas alors vous les laisser
pourrir en laissant pourrir par ailleurs
mais dans la filière courte de la salade
une chaîne de succursales à jouer la
vérité parce que la chaise vide est une
mauvaise politique parce que cette
organisation à d'autres propositions
tranchante sur la distribution
il faut certainement réformer sa fille
distribution d'une part et aussi alléger
certaines normes que l'on exige de plus
en plus sur le calibrage des fruits sur
les emballages qui finalement
alourdissent considérablement le prix
des fruits et légumes et il faut donc en
outre activer la réforme de cette
distribution que vous connaissez puisque
je me bats depuis trente ans pour cette
réforme est aussi peut-être revoir une
certaine production et maîtrise et d'une
autre façon
cette production est ce que vous
monsieur le cloud êtes d'accord dangbo
360 centre de france fondu reproducteurs
nous vous attendons
je dis ceci déjà dans nos régions autres
que la région parisienne puisqu'il est
difficile dans la région parisienne de
se structurer un doute a donné le foot
du terrain il vient je leur demande de
nanterre en relation avec nos centrales
régionales et de faire en sorte que nous
puissions avec leur concours distribué à
un prix abordable pour les consommateurs
et aussi raisonnable pour les
producteurs et cela est facile ils n'ont
qu'à prendre le téléphone est en contact
avec toutes ses centrales régionales des
centres leclerc qui rend les tribunaux
révolutionnaires islamiques voient leurs
compétences encore étendue des
exécutions ont repris on en a compté
neuf aujourd'hui en province dont quatre
pour fait de collaboration avec les
rebelles kurdes mais une délégation du
parti démocrate du kurdistan va dit on
est reçu à terrain les combats entre
l'armée iranienne et les guérilleros ce
kurdes les peshmergas que vous voyez ici
n'ont pas cessé pourtant une délégation
de responsables politiques kurdes est
arrivé à téhéran aujourd'hui pour tenter
de ramener le cas les revendications
kurdes serait que le gouvernement
iranien s'engage à cesser son offensive
militaire en échange les kurdes
accepterait que l'armée iranienne puisse
s'installer dans les villes actuellement
défendue par les pêches mercat des
informations les plus récentes font état
de combats très violents autour des
villes de sanandaj de pavés et de sa
caisse les iraniens auraient perdu
plusieurs chasseurs à réaction
ainsi que des hélicoptères en plus de la
situation de guerre civile qui règne au
kurdistan
l'ayatollah khomeini doit faire face à
des grèves parmi le personnel de
l'industrie pétrolière qui ont déjà
provoqué une baisse de la production
iranienne
à tel point que le gouvernement a dû
commander aux états unis deux millions
de barils de kérosène et de mazuch
bref passage à paris du président du
zaïre le général mobutu
vous savez qu'il y a quelques jours le
zaïre avait été mis en cause après le
rapport des magistrats les africains sur
les massacres d'enfants en empire
centrafrique le président mobutu a tenu
à démentir formellement toute
participation de son armée à ce drame
dans le pays de bokassa il a expliqué
que les soupçons avaient été provoquées
par la présence de deux avions zaïrois à
l'aéroport de bangui la capitale au
moment même où les émeutes étaient mater
de la manière barbare que vous savez le
président mobutu a révélé qu'il avait
lui même là les deux appareils mais
qu'il s'agissait d'une escale technique
et qu'aucun de ses soldats n'avait
participé ou un sacre de boeck
l'allusion qui a été fait à la présence
de métro au sens fort tic et les fausses
donc il n'y a jamais eu de présence des
oiseaux militairement parlant à bangui
capitale de l'empiré en fabriquer mais
des témoins affirment avoir vu des
soldats zaïrois dans les rues de bangui
c'est faux vous savez que c'est faux aux
etats unis d'amérique où une enquête a
été menée pour savoir la vérité
eh bien cela s'est révélé faux au quai
d'orsay savez qu'il ya eu même un
communiqué pour dire on parle de 2 après
enquête cela s'est révélé faux la vérité
c'est ce que je vous dis sur mon honneur
de ceux-là que c'est faux et puis vous
avez la tour de contrôle de dakar
poser la question vous êtes journaliste
en janvier ya eu ce démenti du pays pour
dire l'avion venait des états unis via
dakar contre les contrôler à la tous les
contrôles est ce vrai que cet avion a
passé la nuit à dakar
c'est vrai bon lorsque la viande devait
changer de cap
c'était avec l'autorisation de la tour
de contrôle d'accra accra lien donné que
son ouïe pour dire continuer sur bande
donc la majorité vides s'il y avait des
troupes à bord cette route ne pouvait
être qu american ou sénégalaise mais pas
à y voir
mais on dit aussi que vous troupes ont
défilé pour le premier anniversaire du
couronnement de l'empereur bokassa un
décor c'était le 4 décembre 4 décembre
j'étais là môme 1 ils ont défilé le 4
décembre et le soir même un dc10 est
venu les prendre et se décide à faire de
rotation la tour de contrôle de ben
guité là pour vous dire que mobutu man
ou bien vous vous tous dit la vérité
le soir même du 4 décembre le décider et
elle a deux rotations
je peux pas franchement et je me dis qu
nettement les sources
il n'en reste pas moins que ces
massacres d'enfants tout de même eu lieu
est ce que vous vous approuver
l'atttitude du de l'empereur bokassa est
ce que vous accepterez de lui serrer la
main quand vous le verrez écouter entre
nous mon cher ami je sais que cette
affaire pour vous quelle émotion c'est
considérable non seulement en france
mais elle à travers le monde entier
d'abord je ne suis pas je ne peux pas
mary gestion procureur pour gégé
collègues qui à la tête de son pays a
mal fait ou a bien fait c'est pas ça mon
rôle je vous réponds à cette question
parce qu'on a essayé d'impliquer de
zaïbo vie d'une manière injuste et là on
propose ce n'est pas de démentir ces
mêmes de protester de vous garantir que
c'est faux
vive tension entre les états unis et
l'urss à la suite de la décision prise
avant-hier par le danseur de 2,9 étoile
du ballet du bolchoï de quitter la
troupe et de ne pas retourner à moscou
et de demander le droit d'asile aux
états unis les pousses de l'a29 madame
place aux vannes n'a pas voulu suivre
son mari et elle est montée à bord d'un
avion soviétique pour rentrer chez elle
en urss mais les autorités américaines
retiennent depuis près de vingt heures
d'horloge l'avion sur le terrain de
l'aéroport de new york afin d'être
certain
tel que madame la sauva n'est pas
contrainte par la force à repartir pour
moscou
c'est la guerre des nerfs madame là ça
va a déclaré qu'elle ne comprenait pas
pourquoi les états unis empêché de
repartir on me retient il également dit
m je répèterai tout cela aux enquêteurs
américains qu'il monte me voir à bord de
l'appareil
mais les autorités américaines insistent
pour que les deux époux puisse
s'entretenir d'or de l'avion dans les
locaux de l'aéroport les diplomates
russes refusent et pour le moment c'est
un dialogue sans mission
une autre polémique pour les états unis
celles qui les oppose au mexique à
propos de la gigantesque marée noire
issue du puits de pétrole ixtoc 1 qui
depuis le début du mois de juin
déversent des nappes de pollution dans
le golfe du mexique et touche les côtes
du texas
les etats unis envisagent de demander
une indemnisation les mexicains
répondent que c'est des américains qui
peuplent les eaux du golfe avec des
déchets de toute nature
l'affairé sérieuse un grand quotidien de
mexico par le même de scandale
international
un mois avant la visite du président
mexicain en amérique
les etats-unis ont demandé l'ouverture
de négociations pour l'indemnisation des
dégâts sur les côtes texanes
non seulement le mexique a réagi
immédiatement en refusant tout net une
telle procédure mais a tenu à son tour
les américains de polluer les eaux du
golfe avec leurs déchets industriels et
atomique
en attendant le puits ixtoc 1 continue
de déverser chaque jour l'équivalent de
dix mille barils d'hydrocarbures dans la
mer et les prévisions les plus
optimistes ne prévoit un colmatage
complet qu'en début d'octobre
nous sommes revenus en france à paris
pour une occasion solennelle
c'est aujourd'hui le 25e anniversaire de
la libération de la capitale par les
troupes alliées des troupes françaises
des ffi les ftp et français leurs
partisans et d'autres formations pour ce
35e anniversaire de la grandiose journée
d'août 44
de nombreuses manifestations se sont
déroulées dans la capitale notamment
place de l'hôtel de ville ou en fin
d'après midi devant le front des troupes
les acteurs plantier secrétaires d'état
aux anciens combattants a remis le
fanion du maréchal leclerc de
hauteclocque à monsieur chirac maire de
paris mais qu'elle a prononcée à cette
occasion une allocution
donc paris s'est libéré les ordres d
hitler qui consistait à faire brûler la
capitale de la france
avait pas été exécuté nous allons revoir
un extrait du film paris brûle-t-il
la séquence du retour du général de
gaulle chef du gouvernement provisoire
de la république
après quoi vous verrez un couple bien
émouvant il s'agit de deux parisiens
elle a 80 78 91
ils sont mariés depuis 66 ans et ils ont
près par l'un et l'autre au combat pour
la libération de paris
là non
nous étions sous le feu de la bagarre
les murs de la mairie aurait été trouvé
tard le canot on nous tirait tout pile
le score victor et qu'est ce qui vous a
fait croire que c'était fini longtemps
qu'on sentait que c'était la fin d'abord
les allemands étaient affolés
il faisait des choses qu'ils n'auraient
en était en état avant quelques temps
avant il vole et les bicyclettes pour se
sauver il volé tout ce qui pouvait leur
servir pour pour s'échapper
alors qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
marqué ce jour la touffe tout je peux
pas vous dire quelque chose
plus particulièrement parce que tout est
chouette a fellow alors et vous est ce
qu'avec comment avez vous vécu la
libération je crois que vous avez
participé activement sur les barricades
à ce qu'on a fait là marie c'est que la
basque les devants 4-2 on a monté une
barricade la rue de saintonge
alors comment s'est passée cette
barricade qu'est-ce qui lui paraissent
confusion pour les jours on avait des
nouveaux copains qui menait ne
renforçait et puis on chassait les les
allemands quand ils passaient là je
refais les arabes des vous étiez
trouvait à droite à gauche
vous étiez franc-tireur faits et alors
comment avez vous vécu ce jour de
libération qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
marqué ce jour là
la joie il y avait un jeune homme là et
me lâcher il est décédé maintenant ils
fabriquaient des cocktails
alors tout le monde cherchait des
petites bouteilles se désole car les
bouteilles la bière quelqu'un qui lui
j'étais chez un marchand de couleurs les
remplissaient de 106 ch pourquoi
l'annoncer comme ça qu'ils ont eu un
temps que la côté du square et
maintenant 35 ans après comment
réagissez vous à ces souvenirs salon les
appontements un passé
après ça devient mon étal paru ce jour
des journées profondément émouvante et
ceux qui eurent la chance d'y prendre
part après une longue nuit de
l'occupation de cap rennais ne
l'oublieront jamais sans transition nous
passons aux sports c'est un français qui
est champion du monde à l'épée philippe
riboud dans la poule finale à melbourne
en australie où il rencontrait cinq
adversaires
il a remporté cinq victoires au total il
a donné 25 touches et lui n'a été
touchée que cinq fois
c'est ce que l'on peut appeler une
victoire brillante le dernier succès
français à l'épée dans un championnat du
monde
remonter à 1961 et le vainqueur avait
été jacques dit est l'actuel président
de la fédération française d'escrimé
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
route de mende et professionnels hinault
gagnera team
aujourd'hui c'était l'épreuve des hommes
à terre dont voici l'arrivée sur circuit
le valkenberg au pays
cet après midi aucun français n'a pu
imiter régis ovion 28 ans 71 les plus
actives delteil et questin longtemps
dans le groupe de tête ne peuvent plus
suivre le rythme à 20 km de l'arrivée
mais regardez ici dans les derniers
mètres lickel giacomini prend la route
lallemand de la drogue
il est surpris par le démarrage du
colonne région qu'est vix mais revient
dans les derniers mètres haies
j'ai connu champion du monde amateur
demain place aux professionnels et à
bernard hinault lolita de santé sans
bobos indicatif et il a retrouvé une
certaine sérénité car je pense que c'est
surtout ce qui lui manquait il était un
peu un peu nerveux et je crois qu'il
avait surtout besoin d'un petit peu de
de repos et d'être un petit peu isolée
de du brouhaha les critériums il a
reconnu le parcours ici à l'alcan bur
comment le trouve-t-il difficile c'est
un parcours qui ne la chante pas
spécialement un parcours qui n'est pas
suffisamment difficile au niveau 2
des ascensions des difficultés mais
c'est un parcours qui sera quand même
difficile avec le vent mais ça ne
l'avantagera pas spécialement car soit
on sera beaucoup plus fait pour les
courants batave et les coureurs belges
en espérant aux pays bas également
demain le grand prix de l'or
d'automobiles la zone de vocht c'est un
français rené arnoux qui est réalisé le
meilleur temps aux essais au volant de
sa renault
et c'est donc lui qui partira à la corde
en premier
demain une grande journée hippique d'une
part le seul dimanche du meeting de
vincennes avec des trotteurs de haute
qualité dont vous aurez des images et
surtout le grand prix de deauville pour
les purs sangs le tiercé se disputera
dans le prix europe numéro un handicap
pour juments sur 2000 m voici les
pronostics de pyrène plus un casse et
qui se court dans une course à handicap
peut réserve souvent des surprises parmi
les impôts lige du prix europe numéro un
il est bien difficile de dire qui
l'emportera au bout des 2000 mètres de
course car il faudra également tenir
compte du terrain lourd avec ma fiancée
une grecia je me suis aussi intéressé à
cirfa que montre à henri sa mamie
surface brute avec laquelle je viens de
me passer second evry et ensuite la fois
d'avant j'ai gagné à me paraît pas très
très bien placé au poids de 54 kg elle a
un avantage c'est le démer notaire
assoupli le terrain nous est ce que l'on
est à sa portée vous avez déjà regardé
un petit peu qu'elles seraient partants
willie handicap c'est très difficile
parce que
comme j'ai dit à l'heure il faut avoir
une course déjà très heureuse et s'est
passé ce n'est pas toujours le cas dans
ces gros handicap
il faudra un bon numéro à la corde et
avoir un bon parcours ceci dit une
peluche qui finit très vite elle finit
très bien ses courses et si la course
marche je pense que ça va être sélectif
donc ça lui permettra de finir aussi
bien que les autres fois
personnellement je vais mettre laisser
influencer par patrick biancone qui
compte bien gagner avec ma fiancée je la
place en tête de ma sélection
idrissi avait cassé est chargé avec 56
kg mais c'est une pouliche de grande
qualité elle peut prendre une place sur
ça d'après son entraîneur philippe
laloum cirfa a été préparé pour gagner
cette épreuve donc avec une pouliche
très régulière et ici elle bénéficie
d'un poids favorable avec 52 kg des
fluence est également bien placé dans
l'échelle des poids avec 52 kg et demi
ses chances d'être à l'arrivée sont
sérieuses jake abel 58 kilos et demi n'a
pas la meilleure place puisqu'elles
portent le poids le plus élevé mais sur
sa classe il faut lui faire confiance
howard sera sur sa distance et elle
court toujours bien sur cet hippodrome
il n'est pas impossible que elmira monté
par freddy head viennent créer une
surprise dans cette arrivée
ces points chauds porteront les numéros
9 6 13 17 16 1,18 et aux joues pas vous
suivre
17 6 à 18 ans eh bien le ski nautique
fait des adeptes tous les jours non
seulement parmi les hommes mais aussi
parmi d'autres animaux le dernier
exemple connu est celui de l'écureuil
c'est avec lui que vous avez rendez vous
dans un instant sur le pré cran laissant
lui tout de même le temps de chausser
des planches à l'écureuil
si vous avez un écureuil on peut vous
donner l'adresse le temps demain au nord
de la loire le ciel restera le plus
souvent très nuageux avec des pluies
intermittentes surtout l'après midi les
températures seront basses pour la
saison au sud de la loire le temps sera
passagèrement plus vient début de
journée quelques chutes de neige
pourront même se produire en montagne au
dessus de 1000 mètres près de la
méditerranée à ses belles éclaircies
mais le mistral et la tramontane
souffleront dans l'après-midi espérons
comme les strates nati sera pas trop les
feux ce soir vers 23h15 et bernard
cadinot qui vous donnera des dernières
informations et vous le retrouverez
demain pour antennes de midi le soir à
20 heures
c'est daniel bilalian qui prendra le
relais et je ne terminerai pas sans la
nouvelle que voici qui vous fait plaisir
brunir âge ni si c'est possible partant
dynamique et frais patrick poivre
d'arvor dit ppda présentera à nouveau le
journal de 20h à partir de lundi
geoffrey samedi prochain pour le
week-end bonsoir